it's 20/20 this is my first stream of
the new year of the new decade
no one's here yet always takes like
about 45 seconds for people to arrive so
hopefully I can start off well last term
I played on me chess I kind of collapsed
at the end oh my my readings still
provisional wait what I thought I played
enough classical games over 70 games
maybe I haven't played in a while huh
I'm playing strong player let's play c5
hey it's people first coffin of 2020
it's actually the second comments B Hall
1 3 8 the first comment was from Carrie
on my way saying hi welcome everyone
bicycle aces up thanks so much
also bicycle aces up I did see her your
message with the time stamps but I've
been having trouble exporting the stream
from the marathon tournament because it
was it's like a 13 hour stream let's
play I'll stick with my normal rapper
tour I'll play time on of if if white
plays open Sicilian oh no roof lost a
sub almost as bad as me losing my queen
it's okay a new year there's there's
always many ways to improve ourselves
let's take on D for now I was about to
say it's not a good idea to pre move
knight c6 cuz Bishop g5 is a valid move
c3 also a valid move so we're gonna have
a Smith Maura
accepted campus ringling thanks for
subbing against Smith Mara I like to
play this some Queen c7 line I'll play
an out of six here the main line is
Queen e2 and now I'll play Knight g4 and
tricky move this it's kind of hope chess
I'm hoping white allows this tactic it's
very well known trap each 394 dozen wins
for black black would either win the
Queen or made on h2 so 94 is a major
threats my pawns thinking which probably
means that maybe opponent isn't so well
prepared
I've already I had it maybe maybe a
couple times there's one stream towards
the end of 2019 I had a couple times
yeah we'll see how many times it happens
this year but okay for now I'm just
seeking a normal checkmate Sam welcome
back yeah yeah it's this is long chess
it's a slow chess I'll have time to
interact with the chat except if I
interact with the chat too much then
people and YouTube comments don't
appreciate it they want me to talk about
the position but my opponents thinking
so much here and I do have to be careful
what I say have to be cognizant that my
opponent might be watching but we chess
is we just detecting my stream usually
it would say I'm streaming you refresh
yeah now it says I'm streaming
I wonder if opponent knows oh man my tea
so hot he burned my mouth
okay I have to be patient with the teeth
hello to more people
hello to taggi lead school at school I
have I have a special surprise but I'm
not gonna say it I'll let people
discover it
we'll see who who's the first person to
discover it
Brooke do you want so I was gonna say
Brooke t1 so hold it holding off on
saying this but rook t1 is an inaccuracy
because of this move Bishop c5 and f2 is
actually a major targets and already
black is much better if Rick f1 I have
the same 94 tactic Hey okay people found
the surprise in the chat if people are
watching in the future on YouTube then
they'll probably have no idea what I'm
referring to so I'll share I'll share
what the chat looks like we have the new
newly designed tog II emote
I was up until now I was up was I wake I
was awake at like 3:00 a.m. this morning
and I had nothing to do so I designed a
tog II taki taki much seemed like the
world was in need of a ita'i emote
strategy sy d thanks for subbing so yeah
life is very good right now boo 9595
surprising okay life is getting more
complicated this may be a more accurate
portrayal but what life is like what did
you 95 whoa it's Tiger with 1,000 bits
okay all right I actually kind of have
to focus here because my d5
I mean 95 very typical Smith [ __ ] move
but like free piece pawn takes d5
White's trying to attack me I'm trying
to attack White's thinking just takes
pawn takes okay check in my Knights hits
and then Knights
I mean 97 97 I'm still having f2 getting
ready to Castle rook e1 just Bishop
takes F 2 I mean I have time to think
I'm just I really just making sure I'm
not missing anything
I'm just trying to imagine while I
couldn't be missing here after it takes
takes 97 I mean my knight is a loose my
King is still on the e-file but
everything's defended I'm attacking f2
it's a type of situation like you just
want to want to be hyper aware of the
opponent's ideas Bishop g5 mr. g5 a move
then even f6 like take stakes here
Bishop g5 five six because maybe black
and do something I don't really believe
it though or maybe I can do something
let's take ninety-seven yeah hello two
more people there's always more people
to say hello to too many names it can be
overwhelming chess on earth welcome back
Hudson Viking welcome back stock this
excise sparks
why not Bishop takes off to first if I
were to do this first that's a good
question because I didn't really even
consider it
it is a check there's a few problems
with it
I mean maybe Queen takes f2 is possible
because white is still threatening the
Queen but even something like keen each
one and then if I were to take on d5
white takes back and White's writing h3
in many lines and the pieces are a bit
awkward so I'm already up a piece yeah I
was expecting this move so White's
trying to prevent me from castling okay
times I think hey-hey-hey talkies number
one yeah the the whole leaderboard
resets I forget I should have taken note
who finished it on top last month it was
a wild race but yeah I probably can look
it up anyway um okay I have to be very
careful taking off too now because I
could be mating me
hey uh yeah I think that they loved the
thumbnail but yeah the video was I don't
know it's slightly tragic for me but
people take my pledge or take pleasure
in me getting forked I guess f6
so with f6 i-i induce a bishop back i I
would really want a castle but then g6
I mean g6 is possible here defending
this was also maybe maybe too risky I
don't know it's it's actually weird
there's this funny line Knight takes f2
Bishop takes a 7
Knight takes d1 discover check but then
Bishop takes c5 discover check so a
discovered check met with discovered
check and then I would actually be in
trouble because I have no good way to
block and I'm probably just getting
mated there so let's not do that I mean
there's a smooth 95 to takes in the 94
but then takes and then it's a pin oh
but then I check it just seems like a
mess but I don't want to deal with pick
him up a piece how to make things simple
considering castling here
Cassin might make a lot of sense because
after takes takes takes at Queen takes
e4
so the bishops a bit loose I do leave my
knight kind of he mean temporarily so
maybe there's other moves like there's
d6 but then takes other than rook takes
again it's a mess I might just have to
like power my way through the mess I
mean on all these lines I should be
better cuz I'm up a piece but I'd rather
have a clear path towards advantage
castling and d6 interesting and maybe
this is a move Bishop takes off too but
then the King just moves the bishops
still defended
hmm
in castling in d6
I mean I'm drawn back to f6 because this
is actually an idea here a consolidation
idea f6 Bishop h4 and then d6 so I I try
and like restrict both bishops and
Bishop g3 doesn't hurt me
I guess rook e1 would be most likely and
then there's 95 yes tonight takes e5
pawn takes e5 I'm up at peace queen h v
g6 even Castle queenside in some lines
I think f6 is a way to go I'm not gonna
mess with f2 pawn it's like unnecessary
baits taking on f2 is like taking candy
from a stranger ok let's play off 6 I
feel like Ben Feingold would argue that
f6 is like taking candy from a stranger
or giving candy to I don't know
yes it is yeah it's it's it's myself
reborn for 2020 I don't know how much
has changed so far but yeah i wanted to
stream earlier but it wasn't feeling
well in like the last few days but now
i'm i'm more alive okay d6 time d6 and
there's Bishop b5 even like King f8 King
f8 could be safe yeah
Albert seeing one can be a move uh more
like just sleep getting back on a normal
sleep schedule I feel like I'm still
hungover from the winter marathon it was
a rough tournament
okay let's do let's do this I just like
a little bit worried of this pressure
but I don't think it's anything too
concerning like even if we imagine like
rook c1 castling before Bishop takes
before there's no great discoveries mmm
that's been a while feels like it's been
forever soaking wet sigh welcome back so
many returning names so many new names
lot of names I just I don't remember
seeing before like what does this name
sign on Demetrius Bishop d6 looks better
says the new name yeah Bishop d6 was a
move which maybe I should have played I
guess it would invite Roxy one or even
this move
yeah I probably should have considered
mission t6 but until they know last
decades I think I know what you mean
Kingston thanks for the bits John ghost
John ghosts welcome I say that right I
think I said that right
and a JH thanks people for subbing and a
lot of new subs to start the decade
okay opponent thinking that's good sign
I guess one of the issues with Bishop d6
is it would make this official a bit
more sad now the bishops happier wants
to develop at some point yeah yeah d6 is
a move it would it would open basically
the diagonal on the file but I would
take and then yeah the bishop would
control the square I'd probably slide
over the king at some point I'd also be
attacking the pawn also 95 would come at
some point maybe did I say did I refer
to the bishop as him or he not sure okay
I think it's time to Castle I think
before before shouldn't scare me
another sub rack and Dawson welcome back
I'm just trying to ensure is a like
after I castle the Queen's tied down to
the night and then white stirs up a
little bit of initiative with before
takes vision moves somewhere but in
general
I'll have Queen d8 and that should be
good enough I think I guess there's
Queeny Queeny for Bishop f5 oh but then
this hangs oh wow wow so what keeps
initiative okay so the calculation is
castling and b4 takes Bishop d3
threatening the Queen and threatening
Queenie for with double attack cuz I
would want to play Bishop c5 after
Bishop d3 but I was thinking rook takes
e5 Queen takes e5 I lose this thing I
guess I'm still up the exchange there
maybe that's that's a reasonable way to
trade okay one more time castling b4
takes takes Bishop d3 there's 55 takes
his left take with a pawn there's d6
a happy new year are Beasley welcome
back good to see you back a seven-month
sub on this line with d6 is actually
it's annoying because takes and takes
and stuff so I have to think yeah have
fun with that it's tag is a new decade
gift okay I'm realizing I don't have to
take on before thinking like it's so
natural to take but I could so after
castling before I just played Bishop e6
and I give white the discovery play
Queen d8 allow Queen e4 and then the
Queen's not attacking a bishop my
bishops a
and then I played this by five okay and
if ever each three and ninety five and I
block see file it should be fun fun and
fine
okay let's Castle I think it's very
important especially in these situations
where you're up material but opponent
has good pieces you you just have to be
aware of the points frets and initiative
yeah I forget why I've marked January
seventh as taggi day and my calendar but
I forgot why I guess it's four days
early excise sparks waiting for his own
emotes capital Greco
welcome back Wow for a year so the thing
with emotes there there's a limited
number of slots and I've maxed out the
slots so to have new slots I either have
to delete existing emotes or break song
absurd number of subs I think I need to
break like 1200 subs to get a new emo
Belgian novice gifting subs getting
closer the new subs ooh new subs a lot
of a lot of recognizable names we have
sapphire 73 msu 105 hoop nd Chasse pay
94 shadow to chest pay the Superman and
star ko welcome you subs thanks Belgium
novice appreciate that so many firsts so
the new decade that was the first sub
gift our sub yeah sub gift of the stream
for 2020 and Steven is Daedalus for 10
months
so opponent thinking the thing about
classical chess is like these schemes
can take a long time like I feel like
I've been winning since move
9 but I'm just being extra careful and
trying not to embarrass myself
so Bishop d3 so White's running before a
tricky idea Queens still tied down hey
how we're double-oh-seven
that sounds nice
okay let's stay focused I'm thinking
just queen d8 it's like the same line
except before wasn't played Queen D
eights I mean what is why trying to do
oh there is there's actually kind of an
interesting line I don't think it's too
harmful it's interesting though I'm
gonna play Queen d8 I'll try and explain
[Music]
white side it'd be four okay of course
trying to decoy him the bishop so
Queenie four would be double attack so
let's say B Ford there should be six
then there's nifty move rook takes c8
removing the guard from the night to
prepare Queenie for double attack and I
can't take with Queen because runs into
this but I think I can just take with
rook so before here it takes takes and
then after Queenie 4ev I have five oh
five I lose a knight though huh maybe I
just allow Queen takes h7 and play 95
because White's sacking so much
I guess White has to decide if it's
actually worth going into and I don't
think I really have a choice also new
subs wind ooof colorblind oof gifting a
sub - oops Mouse lip thanks wind oof
okay I think I'm gonna do this
Brook take CA might be coming but I
can't really stop it and then I'll be up
enough material to probably get
something back and still hopefully be
better I'll give in very simple odds
okay let me let me just explain rook
takes rook takes Yeats Queenie for very
simple Knight g6 because Queen takes e4
I'm still up the exchange and I can
start trading and I have bishop oh wait
a minute oh did I miss something I'd
made miss miss something I forgot rook
takes rook takes you there's Queen e6
check
but again I'm like I would be still up
the exchange and maybe even I have this
move so 92 that's probably a good sign
opponent moving backwards but I feel
like there's all these targets
I mean 95 I think is most natural I hit
the bishop I just want to trade I think
I could play this without too much
thought yeah this is kind of what I was
envisioning like back when I played off
six is just having my pawns support the
Knights and block the file hit the
bishop life is good
wyvern your first Eric Rosen stream
welcome welcome to twitch yeah if you're
new here say hi in the chats hopefully
people will say hi back position is
difficult especially when you're down a
piece for a little compensation like
white doesn't even have a pong for the
piece this was a Smith more a gambit
more like a Smith morning gifts maybe
afterwards I can show what light should
have done in the opening because I
played the same line against a sermon a
sermon is very well prepared and so
dangerous to play this exact line
against a sermon are you gonna play the
whole arena well it's a five hour long
tournament do I have this move cuz F the
pawn is pinned there's no F three if
Queenie four I have a five hitting the
the Queen defending h7 and also gonna
win the rook the following move I mean
there's Knight f3 but that would just
mean to happiness let's play Bishop g4
ah okay see you soon
taggi rob Arad thanks for subbing and
halvard hf also thanks for subbing
and soaking wet psy give to the sub I
miss so many things
soaking Oh soaking wet psy gifted a sub
to hollered appreciates all the love
thanks so much
and these tag emotes start filling up
the chat okay um yeah so f5 I forgot
it's still kind of strengthens of
Bishops but I don't think that matters
yeah a 5
yeah very multi-purpose be winning more
material Kings very safe Knights happy
mmm
Nike sixes it's quite appealing even I
mean this is a move so many moves but if
I take the rook I could take their rough
night g6 yeah the point is not so when
like quickly or even trying win the
tournament I'm just trying to to play
clean a solid hopefully instructive
chess it's finite g6 actually can I move
this Knights this might even be stronger
and then maybe even provoke the opponent
to resign quicker because after take
stakes we trade Queens I'm just up a
full rook and then otherwise yeah if the
Queen moves on I win the bishop wouldn't
be surprised if my opponent just for
zines here well does this mean hedge
logo laws thanks for subbing that's a
new name compote Ed's gambit it's not
really a it's it's just a boat Ed's
Queen trade if we can call it that
both Queens are hanging but okay we're
either trading or in winning more
material that's just completely with you
kind of a fuel good game I feel like my
opponents maybe walked into the opening
without really knowing the line okay
let's take okay the game continues I do
have a pawn hanging I'm up a rook many
things to do let's try and be clean I'm
thinking just going for the attack
against F 292 comes to mind I mean this
is a move as well
rook t8 very simple move there should
really be no need to think here but I'm
thinking anyway yeah there you got a
let's play this move yeah I mean if the
pawn is taken and the rook will come in
I'll probably end up trading a bit more
than d5 is weak this is probably
something I have to work on is just like
playing quicker and simple chess when I
have the advantage but okay getting the
job done yeah it is hard to keep up with
the chat and like explain the game was I
see some very nice comments thanks
everyone for the nice feedback I see
some opening recommendations yeah
usually I am open to taking opening
recommendations but if you're gonna
suggest an opening suggest it like as
the next game is starting because I'm
it'll be easier to remember easier to
see to which chest streamers are you
following I make an effort to follow
anyone who streams chests
even even people who are just starting I
find it interesting to see like how how
people approach just streaming and of
what creative ideas are being
implemented yeah I enjoy watching chess
content if you're a chess streamer and
I'm not following you
make yourself heard or send a raid if
you send a raid that's sometimes the
best way for me to to realize who you
are and then I'll try and return the
raid at some points Oh what is this does
this stuff is happening so many things
are like attacking one another I still
want to take on f2 I mean we could just
trade I think there's simple move takes
and then takes
there's also oh there's ninety to ninety
tunas wins a piece another piece okay
you know I thought the opponent was
gonna resign earlier maybe opponent will
resign now pure balkis as I say that
Peter Bacchus thanks for the rating
appreciate that
shout out Peter Bacchus if you guys
don't know who Peter is he's a very
prolific chess streamer opponent resigns
that was a very nice omen raid yeah I'll
just quickly show the opening especially
for I guess the Sicilian players out
there and the Smith Mora players out
there
I guess there's something to learn from
from this variation this is my favorite
variation to play against Smith Mora
because most players will walk into this
position and not know exactly what to do
and I was surprised my opponent didn't
know what to do given the the reading
but yeah Knight g4 is is main line and
it's
it looks ridiculous like moving seeing
piece twice away from the center but it
comes with a very powerful threat and we
can see the leech s database okay it's
not the most common move but it's up
there h3 played 726 x is just losing a
queen or getting needed it was very nice
tactic
we're threatening made into taking with
Jack and queen h2 and we're attacking
the Queen and it takes just me so I've
had a good number of games she wants in
a tournament and then probably handful
of times online and have gone down
similar paths like this so the main move
here is g3 I think the best move is
might be five might be fine no it's not
be five here yet slight be five here
Queen b8 and then e five this is what
Esserman played against me and this is
what white should do to try and keep the
damage and black really has to be
careful here if that gets greedy and
takes the pawn rook e1 is very very
painful
cuz Queen's tied down to the the forking
square if Queen b8 then very strong move
Queen d4 hitting the basically defending
that four square preparing Bishop f4 and
I remember Esserman won a game like this
I think it was on chess calm at some
point in time I I downloaded all of a
sermons chess comm Laura games and
studied his secrets and I remember a
game d6 Bishop f4 oh he has a few games
on me chess to master and mayhem ie 5
and then I think rook takes he 5 yeah
I'm sure this is in his book nasty trap
literal trap the Queen
so yeah with ePHI best move for black is
to play Knight g4 and then after Bishop
f4 there's kind of weird line a 696
takes takes and then castling there's
some nuances like be fine runs into
Bishop d5 castling I played a sermon in
this line he played I think he played h3
and then 95 and then supposedly the best
moves might be for an engine
I think engine is slightly confused if
anyone wants to learn this deeper just
by uh sermons book oh it's taggi thanks
Augie appreciates your love for your
emails and thanks for the bits anyway um
yeah so like my plan for this tournament
was to put like each game on YouTube I'm
trying my best to make things
instructive I know they're kind of slow
games but hopefully some people learn
something so YouTube people watching in
the future I hope you enjoyed that if
you have questions leave a comment
people in the comments are usually good
at and answering questions and stay
tuned for the next video and thanks to
tog II again all right back to
tournaments one game down took a long
time I feel like I moved down in places
wow it's heartwise annual with 10,000
bits oh maybe if maybe I should include
that in the YouTube video too
oh man